we've got to mention we what must
mention the Godfather and yes I think a
lot of people assume that Marlon Brando
was a very good series figure but the
two of you seem to have a lot of fun on
cell phone especially with Jimmy Caan
Jimmy is a here in Bill Murray that to
funniest guys ever worked with and Jimmy
would tell a joke it would take Brando
three seconds to catch on
we had great time yeah I know what
should I know where you're heading well
because you got the mooning yeah because
we all believe me and you know it to
keep this set you know fun so you want
to I'll tell you the best story of all
okay this is absolute true story
we're in Staten Island at the wedding
and Brando he gave our belts at the end
the championship belts of Mooney he went
for his belt I went for my belt and in
couples that come on now they're women
and children I don't but he kept going I
kept going we moved each other moved
everybody some woman tournament mr.
Duvall you you're fine but she turned to
her friend sit but did you catch the
balls on that Brando
these are quite cool for the edge that
they like because your Bonner winter
band could you just as a favor because I
know that you know you some stars like
to give unusual names could you call him
or her up here